[Música]
en la década de 1950 el descubrimiento
de dos nuevos fármacos creó un mercado
multimillonario de antidepresivos
ninguno de ellos estaba destinado al
tratamiento de la depresión de hecho
muchos médicos y científicos creían que
la psicoterapia era el único método para
tratarla el recorrido de décadas de
descubrimientos que siguió revolucionó
nuestro entendimiento de la depresión y
planteó preguntas que no habíamos
considerado antes uno de estos primeros
antidepresivos fue la ionia un fármaco
para el tratamiento de la tuberculosis
en una prueba de 1952 no solo curó la
tuberculosis sino que mejoró el ánimo de
los pacientes que habían sido
diagnosticados previamente con depresión
en 1956 un médico suizo notó un efecto
similar al realizar un ensayo de
imipramina un
antialérgico ambos fármacos afectaron a
un tipo de neurotransmisores las
monoaminas el descubrimiento de esos
fármacos antidepresivos originó la
teoría del desequilibrio químico la idea
de que la depresión es causada por una
insuficiencia de monoaminas en la
sinapsis del cerebro se cree que la
iproniazida la imipramina y otros
fármacos parecidos restauran ese
equilibrio al aumentar la disponibilidad
de monoaminas en el cerebro estos
fármacos se dirigen a diversas
monoaminas que actúan en el amplio Rango
de receptores del cerebro a menudo esto
implica muchos efectos secundarios como
dolores de cabeza náuseas disfunción
cognitiva y dificultades con la memoria
el pensamiento y el juicio para hacer
los fármacos más efectivos y reducir los
efectos secundarios los científicos
empezaron a estudiar los antidepresivos
existentes para hallar qué monoaminas
específicas estaban más asociadas con
mejoras en la
depresión en la década de 1970 varios
investigadores diferentes concordaron en
una respuesta los antidepresivos más
efectivos parecían actuar sobre una sola
monoamina llamada
serotonina ese descubrimiento llevó a la
producción de fluoxetina o prosac en
1988 fue el primero de una nueva clase
de fármacos llamados inhibidores
selectivos de la recaptación de
serotonina o
isrs que bloquean la reabsorción de la
serotonina dejando más disponible en el
cerebro prosac funcionó bien Y tuvo
menos efectos secundarios que los
antidepresivos anteriores menos
efectivos los fabricantes de prosac
trabajaron a su vez en comercializar el
fármaco creando conciencia sobre los
peligros de la
depresión más gente llegó a ver la
depresión como una enfermedad causada
por mecanismos Más allá del control del
individuo lo que redujo la cultura de la
culpa y la estigmatización en torno a la
depresión y más gente buscó
ayuda en la década de 1990 el número de
personas que recibió tratamiento por
depresión se disparó la psicoterapia se
quedó en el camino y la mayoría de las
personas fue tratada solo con
antidepresivos desde entonces se
desarrolló una visión más matizada en el
tratamiento de la depresión y de sus
causas no todas las personas con
depresión responden a los isrs como el
prosac algunos responden mejor a
fármacos que actúan en otros
neurotransmisores o no responden a
ningún
medicamento para muchos una combinación
de psicoterapia y antidepresivos es más
efectiva que ambos por
separado tampoco podemos asegurar Por
qué los antidepresivos funcionan como lo
hacen los niveles de las monoaminas
cambian a las pocas horas de tomar el
fármaco pero los pacientes no sienten
Generalmente el beneficio hasta semanas
después y cuando dejan de tomar los
antidepresivos algunos pacientes nunca
vuelven a tener depresión mientras que
otros
recaen ahora reconocemos que no sabemos
Qué causa la depresión o por qué los
antidepresiv funcionan la teoría del
desequilibrio químico es la mejor
explicación aunque
incompleta no puede ser una coincidencia
que casi todos los antidepresivos actúen
sobre la serotonina lo que no implica
que la deficiencia de serotonina sea la
causa de la depresión si Eso suena raro
piense en un ejemplo más directo las
cremas de esteroides pueden tratar la
erupción que causa la hiedra venenosa
Pero el hecho de que funcionen no
implica que la deficiencia de esteroides
sea la causa de la erupción todavía hay
mucho camino que recorrer para entender
esta enfermedad por fortuna Mientras
tanto tenemos herramientas efectivas
para
tratarla la depresión es la principal
causa de discapacidad en el mundo
asegúrese de conocer los signos y
síntomas y averigüe cómo podría ayudar a
un amigo en dificultades con este
video